heute verlassen wir die Küche denn es
gibt wieder einige neue Öffnung in
meiner Heimatstadt Köln die checken wir
gemeinsam aus und es geht los mit was
schönem zum Frühstücken auf geht's zu
Bad Freunde wir befinden uns hier auf
der Lütticher Straße in Köln mitten im
Belgischen Viertel und der ein oder
andere aufmerksame Zuschauer kennen
vielleicht Brot den Brotladen weil der
mich das ein oder andere Mal schon
eingekauft habe was sie aber nicht kennt
ist Bad aible unser erster Spot die
erste neue Eröffnung dort gibt es
Sandwiches Kaffee und das ein oder
andere Überraschung
wie gut das ganze ist gucken wir uns
drinnen los geht's
[Musik]
super vielen Dank Dankeschön guckt euch
das mal an smoke Chicks Ape witch nicht
Sandwich eight watch wir sind ja bei Bad
aibafos dazu bisschen so eine Minze
Guacamole sieht sehr lecker aus das
sieht auf jeden Fall gut aus und wenn
ihr das hier liest dann seht ihr den
Laden ist wie gesagt nicht wirklich eine
neue Eröffnung sondern hier der Standort
ist neu aber nicht dieses Sandwich das
ist für mich ein Klassiker hier in Köln
das smoke Chips age Mango und smoke
chicken geröstet Kerne bisschen
Mayonnaise brotkohl wirklich ein Genuss
das kennt vielleicht der ein oder andere
der aus Köln kommt oder in Köln war aber
sie sind hier direkt einladen nebenpro
und wer meine Frühstücksbrote kennt und
so weiß ich schwöre auf Brot mit P am
Anfang das ist eine Bäckerei hier aus
Köln die macht unglaublich leckeres Brot
und die haben ein pastrami Sandwich mit
dem Brot von Brot
ich bin sehr gespannt das Brot vom Brot
kommt auch schon tatsächlich danke schön
ja Leute das ist wirklich
ich gehe hier mal rein in die Masse die
Fahne ist mir nicht mit ein bisschen
Koriander drauf für die die es mögen
natürlich auch abgestellt
unglaublicher Crunch auch hier gerade ne
wirklich wunderschön knusprig außen
innen drin wirklich so dieses brutale so
dieses fettige cremige was die
Mayonnaise bringt wirklich eine sehr
krasse frische ich weiß nicht was man
denkt wenn man sowas sieht und es nicht
kennt vielleicht dann so ein Sandwich so
Subway oder so keine Vergleich was ganz
anderes wirklich ein Klassiker hier in
Köln ich war sehr lange sehr traurig als
es das nirgends gab jetzt gibt's endlich
wieder einladen teilweise gab es nämlich
auch gar nicht darüber bin ich auf jeden
Fall sehr froh aber dieses neue Produkt
das passt Rami Sandwich das hat mir
wirklich angetan dass er aber auch das
ist sehr groß statt würde ich schon
sagen aber auch eine sehr positive Art
und Weise
[Musik]
ist auch absolut Großstadt ist und was
ich mir immer schon mal gewünscht habe
ist ein pastrami Sandwich ihr kennt
wahrscheinlich alle vielleicht aus Lukas
Videos cats Delikatessen in New York so
wusste dieses üppige pastramis Sandwich
gibt somit diesen Weißbrot dazwischen
ordentlich pastrami also gepökelte und
geräucherte Rinderbrust sehr fettarm
sehr sehr lecker das gibt es dort und
scheinbar jetzt auch hier allein die
Oberfläche vom Brot hört euch das an
einfach wenn man das hier ist ja was
soll ich Euch erzählen also hier wird
auf jeden Fall nicht geizt das pastram
ist dann durch die bei 12 €. das smoke
Chicks bei 11 50 man kriegt aber auch
wirklich was fürs Geld weil alleine das
Brot und Brot ist halt wirklich richtig
handwerklich gemacht kosten 500 glaube
ich drüben der Anschnitt ist wir haben
das geröstete Brot Senf ordentlich
pastrami Sauerkraut Gewürzgurken klingt
vielleicht gewöhnungsbedürftig für den
ein oder anderen ich gehe jetzt einfach
mal direkt rein in die Masse gerade
jetzt ein bisschen fitness macht ein
bisschen auf Ernährung guckt super
Alternative
[Musik]
das ist wirklich eine Bereicherung
alternativ
ganz gut aus mit dem Angebot auf dem
Kölner gastromarkt sowas hier hat
gefehlt
und genau deswegen wollte ich euch
zeigen ich finde dieses Format was ich
jetzt zum Format entwickelt hat so die
neue Eröffnung ist einfach richtig geil
so wenn man kann so Leuten die sich was
trauen vielleicht was zurückgeben das
ist wirklich geil und als jemand Essen
liebt sollte man das auf jeden Fall
probiert haben ich würde sagen genug der
langen Worte ab geht's zum nächsten Ort
let's go es wieder Zeit für Vesper wir
gehen jetzt am bargeist oder das ist
sowas wie skisoberger habe ich zumindest
gehört und schieße Burger in Berlin ihr
wisst was ich dafür fühle ich bin sehr
gespannt darauf weil wenn sowas also so
Agent Fusion Burger hier in Köln
wirklich gelbe und die gut sind damit
zufrieden da gehen wir hin
hier links rein geht's zu Brot und hier
vorne direkt also wirklich ein Steinwurf
entfernt ist der zweite Spot Hamberger
es gibt zwei Filialen eines auch am
Neumarkt aber wir gehen zu der direkt
hier vorne auf entspannt
[Musik]
QR-Code Karte wir scannen den Hasen hier
mal ein hamberger.de Japanese cuisine
okay das ist schon mal gut zu wissen
weil ich wenn wir nicht ganz sicher
welcher Kultur das hier zuzuordnen ist
gehen direkt auf die Speisekarte das ist
was uns interessiert chicken Cara ARGE
chicken Katze Chicken Teriyaki Sticks
und Tempura chicken die USA das klingt
schon mal gut so klassische japanische
starters und jetzt hier Japanese beef
Burger Steak Burger okay so wie es
verstehe es gibt schon mal kein Bulgari
Burger mariniertes Rindfleisch klingt
aber auch wild ist von der Macher hat er
ja ganz ähnlich wie beim Ski so Burger
in Berlin weil da war es ja auch
mariniertiertes Fleisch was im Burger
Patty formen dann auf dem Burger kam
dieses Bulgogi beef was ich da so sehr
liebe ist halt so quasi ein Steak nur so
geschafft ne also so dünne Steak
Streifen mariniert angebraten aber
geschmacklich sollte das keinen großen
Unterschied machen Hamburger Steak
Burger ist auch direkt der teuerste 1260
130 Gramm Steak was haben wir denn sonst
noch außer Burger und bowls Rahmen auch
aber ich habe irgendwie Lust die Burger
zu testen doch
einmal chicken und dann vielleicht noch
als Vorspeise Teriyaki Sticks oder ja
danke schön so hier haben wir die beiden
Burger es ist doch der Samen Burger
geworden weil der Chickenburger leider
Soundbar klingt auch sehr gut dass dann
fühlt sich sehr sehr fluffig an auch
hier ist das Rindfleisch so ein bisschen
geschnitten das ist kein reines Steak
das hat mich auch ein bisschen
überrascht es sieht nicht ganz so aus
wie so ein bulgury Burger weil das ist
irgendwie noch saftiger also es hat
weniger röst da oben irgendwie die
heraki Sticks haben wir noch dazu
bestelltlich 12 für den hier okay aber
wenn das jetzt schmeckt wie ein Burger
dann ist mir alles egal ich gehe aber
erstmal hier in Teriyaki Stick rein
kennt man glaube ich irgendwie so aus
dem Sushi Restaurant oder so
schöner Appetizer chicken schön saftig
hätte es jetzt schlecht geschmeckt hätte
mich sehr überrascht weil ich habe den
Laden gesehen wirklich sehr stilvoll
eingerichtet direkt mit zwei Standorten
gestartet also da ist auf jeden Fall
jemand mit viel Plan dahinter bevor wir
die wichtigste Frage klären ob das wie
ein Burger schmeckt nehme ich mir einmal
den Samen Burger jetzt wo ich den zum
ersten Mal in der Hand habe das ist so
das ist ultraleicht fluffig und das
erinnert mich absolut schon an Shisha
Burger wir haben hier einen schönen
angetastetes
Blattspinat Tomate und unten so
gegrillten Lachs also relativ simpel ich
bin gespannt ob das eine Standard mario
ist ob das eine besondere Soße ist
[Musik]
hat durch diese üppige Soße auch so ein
bisschen was von dem Fischbrötchen finde
ich irgendwie das Bank ist ein Traum es
geht schon sehr stark in die Richtung
von dem Ski so Burger Band
in meinem Leben auch deine oder war auch
mein Herz dann
ist schon irgendwie geil so mit dieser
Mai und so also du weißt was ich meine
mit dem Baden
das süße kommt glaube ich von der Lasur
oder Glasur auf dem Lachs der Bürger gut
euch das an auch hier wieder Platz
Spinat bisschen rote Zwiebel Käse ich
bin gespannt kurzer Prozess
diese rote Soße hier oben drauf ich
glaube dass diese gotschwangsoße glaube
ich spreche das richtig aus die genau
die Soße ist auch auf dem Schießen
ich frag mich aber ob der nicht noch
mehr umami hat auf jeden Fall ist er
saftiger also
aber das ist schon krass also ich finde
es sehr lecker für Köln eine gute
Alternative aber nicht eins okay den
würde ich safe noch mal bestellen aber
wenn jetzt eine Tür weiter wäre
würde ich sagen aber es ist trotzdem
[Musik]
ist das mindestens Nacht von 10 auf
jeden Fall auf jeden Fall und
interessant ist auch wir gucken uns neue
Eröffnung an heute morgen hatten etwas
das gab's noch nicht und auch das hier
ist eine Neuerung ich finde es schön
dass jetzt nicht der hundertste Pizza
Laden aufmacht oder der tausendste
Dönerladen so sondern wirklich Sachen
die neue Produkte bringen die die Szene
die fußsehne die genießt hast den nach
vorne bringen sehr lecker wirklich sehr
lecker und jetzt habe ich Lust auf einen
Kaffee deshalb sind wir zwei rein Street
coffee ich wollte den Laden die ganze
Zeit schon ausprobieren ich habe ihn
irgendwann mal gesehen als hier vorbei
gefahren bin und ganz ehrlich ich liebe
Kaffee
ist so eine Leidenschaft auch ein Hobby
von mir deshalb bin ich gespannt was der
laden kann und freue mich euch zu zeigen
gehen wir mal rein
[Musik]
so was braucht man mehr als einfach so
einen schönen Kaffee nach einem Tag an
dem man ordentlich gegessen hat mir
fällt nichts besseres ein Problem mir
mal
der Kaffee schmeckt auf jeden Fall echt
gut die machen mit Sicherheit keine
Raketenwissenschaft aus dem Kaffee
machen es gibt ja zum Beispiel the
coffee Gang die sehr sehr krassen Kaffee
machen wir sind hier an der Ehrenstraße
also an einer der Haupteinkaufsstraße
von Köln und hier kriegt man in einem
schönen Kaffee leckeren Kaffee
Cappuccino auf die Hand für 2,40 €. das
muss man schon sagen das ist sehr fair
probiert mal das Bananenbrot von dem ich
mir eine Scheibe geholt habe ich kann
mir mal ein bisschen
das ist schon schön saftig drin saftig
Banane zweifelsohn war das heute auf
jeden Fall trotzdem cooler und vor allem
sehr leckeren Tag die ein oder andere
Sache bleibt mir auf jeden Fall eine
Erinnerung und die werde ich nicht zum
letzten Mal besucht haben ist bestimmt
der ein oder andere die ich nicht zum
letzten Mal besucht haben werde ich
hoffe das Video hat Euch gefallen ich
würde den letzten Spot hier so eine
sieben von zehn geben wir sehen uns beim
nächsten Video wieder ich habe die Tage
was Verrücktes vor das kommt auf euch zu
bis dahin macht's gut und Ciao bye bye